welcome to this video playing
international master Vaska from croatia
no servia I'm sorry I'm sorry does this
flag of always confuse me by the way if
you noticing that term in the in some
blitz games at the moment there are some
weird rating changes and lots of games
own inner Oasis one color like white or
black in in a row it's because of my my
cold actually once in a while I try to
play a game and then just need to cancel
the recording because my voice fails me
or something like that so when these are
not complete completely a collection of
all games i'm just uploading what's
usable okay let's see yeah I completely
attack this is the some line that are
not into a pile of plate I think oh I
have no idea how this is played I e5
ready okay okay okay Queen a for iOS is
got be five if I was just briefly
thinking I can play Queen a phone I know
that there are lines where you can
actually sacrifice all this just done
can I just play we should be to come on
i know i think i think i can actually
castle him there is a line like that but
i don't know it so let's just continue
to develop
yeah this is a pretty typical position
for a Catalan gambit why it has got
dominance in the center and the bishops
in this case black of course has got the
pawn quite often if players is focused
on the King side so I'm trying to get
some pieces over there is so much is
really weakening the kingside
surprisingly okay let's go here have
this night ready for some direct action
against the king what am I how am I
supposed to get more pieces over them
okay I shouldn't exchange Queens this
cannot be right but but but but that dug
in this concrete position if i take play
five the rook is hanging okay but let's
let's not I don't really want to
exchange here f4 f5 luckily one of the
many ideas okay let's play a form if he
goes f5 I can okay he doesn't okay let's
let's push at five this opens up opens
up the room from our pieces he cannot
take twice only four because of light h6
check at the end
winning the Queen and yeah look locate
what you don't get it night h6 it took
like 20 seconds to to overlook that now
sometimes it happens you especially if
you take some time you tend to overlook
simple things yeah Queenie 496 yeah bit
of a shame this would have been very
interesting it looks like i have a nice
attack but not sure how how dangerous it
really was guys probably needs some time
to do black forfeits due to this
connection no it's the disconnection
resign okay yeah let's let's check
briefly if it doesn't take um what what
is a good more fearful black what what
I'm trying to do is I pile up here like
Brooke this rope here Brooke age five I
have basically all pieces besides the
bishop on G to get towards the kingside
attack so it's it's dangerous I also
have this idea once the rook has moved
so it's clear that i have got good
practical chances especially considering
that those pieces don't really
contribute to the defense funny enough
for the first means that the computer
suggests is nigh day for which really
looks fundamentally wrong to me I mean
where are you going here I mean you
certainly get made it before that but
black should play some some proper
defense moves maybe this one this is
actually a good idea
going to 2d6 at least they're this make
sense yeah and then let's say here just
to continue the line and then this is a
very nice computer suggestion Bishop h3
activating this Bishop yeah interesting
would have been a very interesting game
but unfortunately just blundered the
piece and then disconnected you know in
fact a thing in the opening I think
white can actually castle here I know it
looks insane but I think this is
actually a line maybe I'm talking
nonsense here or is it slightly
different hmm it looks completely wacky
in you should pay three yeah let's say
something like this is possible but ok
the way I played I think was okay as
well alright thanks for watching